Imagine having Alzheimer's disease or having a hard time seeing and hearing.
These age-related health challenges...
...can now be experienced through virtual reality or VR.
Carrie Shaw founded Embodied Labs, a company that immerses a user...
...into the world of the elderly to better understand their reality.
The experiences include hearing the confusion...
...related to memory loss from Alzheimer's...
What was I looking for?
...to visual impairment.
Shaw's mother suffered from Alzheimer's disease.
She realized even professional caregivers...
...found it challenging interacting with her mother.
The company offers the software and hardware needed for the VR experience...
...to help users develop empathy.
Jamie Hannans uses Embodied Labs to train nursing students.
She says this VR experience with macular degeneration opened her eyes.
For now, Embodied Labs only sells to services for the aging...
...because Shaw says...
...it's important that VR is paired with a guided discussion and reflection...
...to process what the users experienced...
...so they know how to put into action what they've learned.
Elizabeth Lee, VOA News, Los Angeles.